This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. I'm going to tell you a story first about how a building got designed, a very unusual building in New York. The City Corp Tower. When it was built in 1977, City Corp Center was, at 59 stories, the seventh tallest building in the world. You know, I can still remember the first time I saw the City Corp Center. As you exit the local six subway station at Lexington and 53rd in Midtown Man, Hatton-Yor confronted by a sheer 915 foot building face, shooting up right from your feet. That's reporter Joel Werner.
这里是“99%隐形”播客。我是罗曼·马尔斯。我首先要给大家讲一个关于一座建筑是如何设计的故事，这是纽约一座非常不同寻常的建筑——花旗集团中心。当它于1977年建成时，59层高的花旗集团中心是当时世界上第七高的建筑。你知道，我依然记得我第一次看到花旗集团中心时的情景。当你从列克星敦大道和第53街的6号地铁站出口走出来，来到曼哈顿中城时，你会迎面看到一座高达915英尺的垂直建筑立面，从你的脚下拔地而起。那是记者乔尔·维纳。
With its gleaming facade, glass and steel and striking 45 degree angle crown the CityCork Centre is truly one of the most spectacular skyscrapers on a skyline known for its spectacular skyscrapers but really it's the base of the building that takes your breath away this massive 59 story skyscraper levitates mid air, hovering 115 feet above the street corner. At first glance, the building seems to violate the basic laws of physics. When you look up, you look directly at the underside
凭借其闪耀的外立面、玻璃与钢材结构，以及引人注目的45度角屋顶，花旗集团中心绝对是天际线中最壮观的摩天大楼之一，而这片天际线本就以壮观的摩天大楼闻名。但真正让你屏息凝神的，其实是建筑的底部。这座宏伟的59层摩天大楼仿佛悬浮在半空中，悬空在街道拐角上方115英尺处。乍一看，这座建筑似乎违背了基本的物理定律。当你抬头向上看时，你会直接看到建筑转角的底部。
of the building corner, it overhangs the sidewalk. I mean, we'd expect a collar more even the grounds. Instead there's nothing. Just in there. Of course the building isn't really levitating. It's propped up on stills, which join the building at the midpoint of each side. It does not look starting. But it's got to be starting. It's got to be safe and they wouldn't have built it this way. Right? Yeah well that's a secret about this building. And it was literally a secret for nearly two decades after it was built.
它悬挑在人行道上方。我的意思是，我们通常会期待一个更宽阔、更扎实的基座。然而这里却什么都没有，只有空气。当然，这座建筑并不是真的在悬浮。它是由高柱支撑的，这些支柱与建筑每个侧面的中点相连。这看起来很不寻常。但它肯定是非同寻常的。它必须是安全的，否则他们不会这样建造它。对吧？好吧，这就是这座建筑的一个秘密。而且在它建成后的近二十家里，这简直是一个秘密。
The City Corp Center could very well have blown over in the wind. What I wanted to know was when was this building going to fall down? The architect of the City Group Center was Hugh Stubbins, but most of the credit for this building is given to the chief structural engineer William Lamezir. You're laughing me, but I did conceive it on a napkin at a Greek restaurant in Cambridge. Lamezir passed away in 2007. This is him giving a talk at MIT in 1995.
花旗集团中心在风中很有可能会被吹倒。我想知道的是，这座建筑到底什么时候会倒塌？花旗集团中心的设计师是休·斯塔宾斯，但这座建筑的大部分功劳都归功于首席结构工程师威廉·勒梅苏尔。你在笑我，但我确实是在剑桥的一家希腊餐馆的餐巾纸上构思出它的。勒梅苏尔于2007年去世。这是他在1995年麻省理工学院的一次演讲。
The whole problem was to build a building on a site that has a church in one corner. St. Peter's Lutheran Church. A chummy old building. It was the lowest point of Victorian architecture. I don't think it was that bad. St. Peter's sat at the corner of the lot. And when the church sold their land to CityCorp, it was on the condition that they build a new church in the exact same location. Beyond that, the company was free to build their skyscraper around the church and in the airspace above it. So, a plan was hatched to float the building over the church, hence the stilts. And because the church was in the corner of the lot,
整个问题的核心在于，要在场地的一个角落里有一座教堂的地块上建造一座建筑。圣彼得路德教会教堂。一座舒适的老建筑。它是维多利亚时代建筑的最低点。我不认为它有那么糟。圣彼得教堂坐落在地块的角落。当教堂将他们的土地卖给花旗集团时，条件是他们必须在完全相同的位置重建一座新教堂。除此之外，公司可以自由地围绕着教堂以及它上方的空域建造他们的摩天大楼。于是，一个让建筑漂浮在教堂之上的计划出炉了，也就是这些支柱的由来。因为教堂位于地块的角落，
LeMesh put the stilts in a kind of a weird place. You couldn't have columns in the corners where they ought to be in a conventional building, so they were removed to the middle. Placing the columns at the midpoint of each side, rather than in the corners, made the building less stable. So, for additional support, LeMesh had designed a chevron-bracing structure. Essentially, rows and rows of Vs each 8 stories high, pointing down the middle of each building face, to where the supporting columns had been moved. Actually, the architect wanted to keep the building simple,
勒梅苏尔把支柱放在了一个有点奇怪的位置。你不能像在传统建筑中那样把柱子放在应该放置的角落里，所以它们被移到了中间。将支柱放在每个侧面的中点而不是角落里，使得建筑的稳定性降低了。因此，为了获得额外的支撑，勒梅苏尔设计了一种人字形支撑结构。本质上，这是一排又一排的V字形结构，每个结构高8层，指向每个建筑立面的中间，也就是支撑柱被移到的地方。实际上，建筑师希望保持建筑简单，
that it's skinned because there was so much drama going on at the bottom and at the top. Anyway, he said, no, if you're going to have any diagonals, I don't ever want to see them. So the Chevron Brazing Structure was slipped under the skin of the building. It formed the CityCorp Center's skeleton. Now, one of the amazing things about this Chevron Bracing structure is that it's so lightweight that when the wind blows, it is more dynamically excitable than a building that weighed twice as much. In other words, it moves with the wind, which most people find really unsettling. Understandably, right? So, LeMeshert added something called a tuned mass damper.
它的外表皮，因为底部和顶部已经有太多的戏剧性变化了。无论如何，他说，不，如果你要用任何对角线，我绝对不想看到它们。所以人字形支撑结构被滑进了建筑的外表皮之下。它构成了花旗集团中心的骨架。现在，关于这个人字形支撑结构，最惊人的事情之一是它非常轻巧，以至于当风吹过时，它比重量两倍的建筑更容易产生动态共振。换句话说，它会随风摆动，大多数人觉得这真的很让人不安。可以理解，对吧？所以，勒梅苏尔添加了一种叫做调谐质量阻尼器的东西。
The tuned mass damper is a massive concrete, which is 29 feet square and about 8 feet thick and weighs 400 tons. It is floated on pressurized oil bearings. The device sits at the very top of the building and acts to steady the oscillations. It offsets the wind gusts. So to recap, we have a 59-story tower floating on 115-foot stilts. Stilts which are not in the corner where you'd expect them, but rather in the middle of each side of the base with a skeleton of beams shaped like V's which make it super light
调谐质量阻尼器是一个巨大的混凝土块，长宽为29英尺见方，厚约8英尺，重达400吨。它漂浮在加压油轴承上。这个装置位于建筑的最顶端，起到稳定摆动的作用。它抵消了阵风的影响。所以我们来总结一下，我们有一座高59层、漂浮在115英尺高支柱上的大厦。这些支柱不在你想象中的角落里，而是在基座每个侧面的中间，并拥有一个形状像V字的梁骨架，这使得它对摩天大楼来说超级轻盈。
for a skyscraper. And to stop it from swaying in the wind, there's a 400 ton block of concrete on the roof, totally ingenious, really cutting edge design. And LeMesh's a pro, so in accordance with the New York City Building Code, he runs all kinds of mathematical models to make sure the building is going to hold up. And everything seemed just fine until, as LeMedre tells it, he got a phone call. June, 1978. I'm in my office.
为了防止它在风中摇晃，屋顶上有一个400吨重的混凝土块，这绝对是天才般的、非常前沿的设计。勒梅苏尔是个专家，因此根据纽约市建筑规范，他运行了各种数学模型，以确保这座建筑能够支撑得住。一切似乎都很好，直到正如勒梅苏尔所说，他接到了一个电话。1978年6月。我在办公室里。
I got a call from a student. I do not know the school. I wish he would call me from the past he never has, but anyway, as a real student from New Jersey, I think he was an architectural student, and his teacher had given him this building to study and report on because it's unusual. As LaMesa tells it, this precocious college senior calls him up to ask how his building structure is going to cope
我接到一个学生的电话。我不知道是哪个学校。我希望他能从过去给我打电话，他从来没有，但无论如何，一个来自新泽西的真实学生，我想他是一个建筑学学生，他的老师把这座建筑交给他研究并写报告，因为它是如此不同寻常。正如勒梅苏尔所说，这个早熟的大学高年级学生打电话给他，询问他的建筑结构将如何应对
with quartering winds. An undergraduate student calling out the head of a world-renowned engineering firm on one of the most innovative skyscraper designs of it today. Cordering wins, the wins that caught the students' attention, are those that hit the building on the corner, exerting pressure on two faces at once. Lamexious calculations on the perpendicular wins, wins that hit the face of the building square on, seem to be fine.
斜向风。一个本科生竟然向一位世界知名的工程公司负责人对当今最具创新性的摩天大楼设计之一提出质疑。斜向风，也就是引起学生注意的风，是指那些从建筑角部吹向建筑的风，同时对两个立面施加压力。勒梅苏尔对垂直风（即直击建筑正面的风）的计算似乎没有问题。
But as the story goes, the student raised the alarm about CityCorp Centre being particularly vulnerable at its corners. It turns out the measure had never run the numbers on what cornering winds would do to the building because normally buildings are strongest at their corners. But this is no normal building. Remember what's going on here? Supporting columns shifted to the midpoint of each building face, the chevron bracing skeleton, and the unusually light mass of the building.
但据故事所说，这名学生对花旗集团中心在角部特别脆弱敲响了警钟。事实证明，勒梅苏尔从未计算过斜向风会对建筑产生什么影响，因为通常建筑在角部是最坚固的。但这不是一栋普通的建筑。还记得这里发生了什么吗？支撑柱移到了每个建筑立面的中点，人字形支撑骨架，以及建筑异常轻盈的质量。
Taken alone, no one of these design quirks should have presented a problem. But as the student told LaMesa taken together, they left Citicorp Centre particularly vulnerable to a wind striking the structure at its corners. And when Lemezure started to investigate the student's claims, he realized that the root of the problem had to do with a change that had been made to the original plans. It had to do with how the Chevron Bracene structure was fastened together. Lemezure's plan originally called for the joints to be welded.
单独来看，这些设计怪癖中的任何一个都不应该构成问题。但正如那个学生对勒梅苏尔所说，综合起来，它们让花旗集团中心对从建筑角部袭击结构的风显得格外脆弱。当勒梅苏尔开始调查学生的说法时，他意识到问题的根源与对原始计划所做的一项更改有关。这与人字形支撑结构的紧固方式有关。勒梅苏尔的计划最初要求接头采用焊接方式。
With full penetration welds, but the contractor had suggested using bolts instead. Bethlehem Steel actually designed beautiful bolted connections for the forces that my people gave them. It was a cost-saving measure. Lamejra says that this change would have happened without his knowledge. Given the wind load calculations Lamejra's team had supplied, welding these v's together was overkill. Run the math, and it looked like bolts would do just fine.
采用全熔透焊缝，但承包商建议改用螺栓。伯利恒钢铁公司实际上根据我的人提供给他们的受力情况，设计了漂亮的螺栓连接。这是一项节省成本的措施。勒梅苏尔说，这一改动是在他不知情的情况下发生的。鉴于勒梅苏尔团队提供的风荷载计算，将这些V形结构焊接在一起有点大材小用。进行数学计算后，结果显示螺栓完全可以胜任。
And bolts would have done just fine, I'm pretty much any other building, except City Corp Center had an Achilles heel on each of its four corners. Lameja could now see what no one else had. No one except for that Pesky student from New Jersey. And as Lameja started looking into the students' claims about these quartering wins, he realized the situation wasn't just bad. It was a disaster waiting to happen. The return period to failure was 16 years.
对于几乎任何其他建筑来说，螺栓也都能胜任，但花旗集团中心的四个角上都有一个阿喀琉斯之踵。勒梅苏尔现在能看到别人看不到的东西了。除了那个来自新泽西的讨厌学生之外，没有人看到。当勒梅苏尔开始调查学生关于这些斜向风的说法时，他意识到情况不仅仅是糟糕。这是一场等待发生的灾难。失效的重现期是16年。
Think about that. Here's what that means. Lameja calculated the quartering win velocities required to topple the city corp center. He then matched these velocities to weather patterns to see how frequently, on average, winds strong enough to blow the building over, occurred. Lameja found that a storm strong enough to knock over the building hits New York City on average, once every 55 years. But that's only if the Tune Mass damper is working.
想想看。这意味着什么。勒梅苏尔计算了吹倒花旗集团中心所需的斜向风风速。然后，他将这些风速与天气模式进行匹配，以查看平均而言，大到足以将建筑吹倒的风发生的频率有多高。勒梅苏尔发现，足以吹倒建筑的风暴平均每55年袭击一次纽约市。但这前提是调谐质量阻尼器正在工作。
The Tune Mass damper needs power to run, and if you're getting a huge storm, the measure realized it's not unlikely that the city could suffer a blackout. The measure ran the numbers again, this time imagining the damper without power. Without the damper, a storm strong enough to topple City Corp Center hits New York on average once every 16 years. To put this another way, for each year the building was standing there was about a one-in-sixteen chance of a storm potent enough to take out the City Corp Center. This building is 915 feet high.
调谐质量阻尼器需要电力才能运行，如果你遭遇了一场巨大的风暴，勒梅苏尔意识到纽约市很可能会遭受大面积停电。勒梅苏尔重新计算了数据，这一次他设想阻尼器在没有电力的情况下。如果没有阻尼器，一场足以吹倒花旗集团中心的风暴平均每16年就会袭击一次纽约。换句话说，在这栋建筑耸立的每一年里，都有大约十六分之一的机率发生一场威力足以摧毁花旗集团的风暴。这座建筑高915英尺。
If it failed, it would topple sideways in the wind, crashing into other Manhattan skyscrapers. A whole slew of buildings from mid-downto central park would fall like dominoes. What is this thing in real trouble? This brand-new skyscraper was on the verge of catastrophic failure. But the imminent disaster wasn't the result of one glaring oversight. Rather, it was a sequence of minor issues. Let's remember how we got here.
如果它倒塌了，它会在风中向侧面倾倒，撞向曼哈顿其他的摩天大楼。从市中心到中央公园的一大批建筑会像多米诺骨牌一样倒塌。这东西真的是陷入大麻烦了吗？这座崭新的摩天大楼正处于灾难性倒塌的边缘。但即将发生的灾难并不是某一个巨大疏忽的结果，而是由一系列小问题导致的。让我们回想一下我们是怎么走到这一步的。
This building was on stilts because they had to build over the church. And stilts placed at the corners would have been just fine, except the church was at the corner of the lot, so the stilts had to be in the middle of each face. And that could have been a-okay, except the offset stilts led Le Mégis to use an ultra-light chevron-bracing structure, which would have been perfectly adequate, except in the end, those chevron-vies were bolted, not welded together. And even that could have been fine, except no one thought about how vulnerable this crazy
这座建筑之所以建在支柱上，是因为它们必须建在教堂上方。如果支柱放在角落里本来会很好，但教堂位于地块的角落，所以支柱必须放在每个立面的中间。本来这也完全没问题，但偏置的支柱导致勒梅苏尔使用了超轻的人字形支撑结构，这本来也完全足够，直到最后，那些人字形的V形结构是用螺栓固定而不是焊接在一起的。即便如此也可能没问题，直到没有人考虑过这个疯狂的设计
design was to wind blowing at its corners. No one except an anonymous college student. The measure went to CityCorp Chairman Walter Riston and told him they would need to open up the building and weld it back together. And how much is going to cost? I don't think it's going to cost an awful lot. Million or two? That's nothing. We're building
对吹向其角部的风是多么脆弱。除了一个匿名的大学生，没有人想到。勒梅苏尔找到了花旗集团董事长沃尔特·里斯顿，告诉他他们需要打开建筑并将其重新焊接在一起。这要花多少钱？我觉得不会花太多钱。一百万还是两百万？那不算什么。我们建造成本是
the cost of $155 million and if it falls down. From here, the Measure and E's team worked with the city called Big Wigs to coordinate emergency repairs on the building. With the help of the NYPD, they worked out an evacuation plan spanning a 10 block radius. They had 2,500 red cross volunteers on standby and three different weather services employed 24-7 to keep an eye on potential wind storms. They welded through the night and quid at daybreak just as the building occupants returned to work.
1.55亿美元，如果它倒塌了。从这里开始，勒梅苏尔和他的团队与城市大人物合作，协调建筑的紧急维修。在纽约警察局的帮助下，他们制定了一个跨越10个街区半径的疏散计划。他们有2500名红十字会志愿者处于待命状态，并雇用了三个不同的气象服务机构进行24小时全天候监控，以密切关注潜在的风暴。他们在夜间进行焊接，并在天亮时收工，恰好赶在建筑使用者返回工作岗位的时候。
But all this happened in secret over three months without telling anyone who worked there. Which is the part of the story I kinda have a problem with. I mean, isn't this situation serious enough to warrant informing the building's tenants? My wife works in a skyscraper in Midtown Manhattan and you know, it's about informed consent. I'd want her to be able to make the judgement called about whether or not to go work in a faulty building. Not to haven't made for her.
但这一切都在秘密中进行了三个月，没有告诉任何在那里工作的人。这也是我对这个故事有点意见的部分。我的意思是，难道这种情况不够严重，不足以有理由通知建筑的租户吗？我妻子在曼哈顿中城的一座摩天大楼里工作，你知道的，这是关于知情同意。我希望她能够就是否去一栋有缺陷的建筑上班做出判断，而不是由别人为她做出决定。
Their thinking was, a contingency plan was in place and ready to be invoked as soon as a storm strong enough to blow the building down was in striking distance of New York. Except… There was a giant storm racing up the east coast. Hurricane Ella. Lameja says the powers that be were just hours away from calling in the evacuation. But the hurricane veered into the Atlantic before it hit New York, and in the end, the public was never notified. And I know what you're thinking. If only there was some kind of independent organization that serves the public's right
他们的想法是，应急计划已经到位，并准备在风暴大到足以将建筑吹倒且进入纽约打击范围内时立即启动。除了一场沿着东海岸疾驰而上的巨大风暴——艾拉飓风。勒梅苏尔说，当权者距离下令疏散只有几个小时了。但飓风在击中纽约之前转向了大西洋，最终，公众从未被通知。我知道你在想什么。要是能有某种独立的组织来维护公众的知情权就好了
to know that might wonder why. City Corp Center was a glow with blow torches all night every night, you know, something like a newspaper. Except the New York Times was on strike. Not only did the New York Times go on strike, but all the newspapers in the war went on strike until October. So we had a pressed blackout and that was the greatest thing that ever happened. So word never got out and construction was finished.
，可能会好奇为什么花旗集团中心整晚整晚地闪烁着焊枪的光芒，你知道的，类似于报纸的东西。除了《纽约时报》正在罢工。不仅《纽约时报》罢工，而且直到10月，战争中的所有报纸都在罢工。所以我们遭遇了新闻灯光管制，那是发生过的最棒的事情。因此消息从未走漏，施工完成了。
And City Corp Center has remained standing ever since. Long enough to be renamed City Group Center and later, 601 Lexington. And this whole thing remained a secret for almost 20 years. In the early 90s, writer Joe Morgan Stern overheard the story being told at a party. He interviewed LaMesa and broke the story in the New Yorker in 1995. LaMesa went on to tell the story publicly, like he did at MIT, which is how we have him talking about this. And after the story got out, it was written up as a textbook case of good ethics in structural
花旗集团中心从那时起一直屹立不倒。时间长到足以被重命名为花旗集团中心，后来又被称为列克星敦大道601号。而整件事作为一个秘密保持了近20年。在90年代初，作家乔·摩根斯恩在一次聚会上无意中听到了这个故事。他采访了勒梅苏尔，并于1995年在《纽约客》上发表了这个故事.勒梅苏尔后来开始公开讲述这个故事，就像他在麻省理工学院所做的那样，这就是我们为什么会有他谈论这件事的录音。故事传开后，它被作为结构工程中良好道德的教科书案例写进了教材。
engineering. New York was spared a tremendous loss of life and the annihilation of its skyline, all because Bill Lamege was humble enough to give time to the inquiry of an undergraduate student. Thank goodness for this uppity-colored senior and his thesis and kudos to Bill Lamege who, through his humility and heroism, saves the day. And that's really the end of this story. Accept. Now wait a minute, there are a couple more things here.
纽约免于了一场巨大的生命损失和天际线的毁灭，这一切都因为比尔·勒梅苏尔足够谦逊，愿意倾听一个本科生的询问。感谢这个傲慢的大学高年级学生和她的论文，向比尔·勒梅苏尔致敬，他通过自己的谦逊和英雄主义挽救了局面。这真的是这个故事的结局。除了。现在等一下，这里还有几件事。
Let's take a step back and remember how this story starts. I got a call from a student. He was a real student from the Jersey. It was an architectural student. This teacher had given him this building to study. I do not know the school. I wish he would call me. The way LaMesha tells it and had Joe Morgan Stern told it in the New Yorker,
让我们退一步，回想一下这个故事是如何开始的。“我接到一个学生的电话。他是一个来自新泽西的真实学生。他是个建筑学学生。他的老师把这座建筑交给他研究。我不知道是哪个学校。我希望他能给我打电话。”正如勒梅苏尔所讲述的，以及乔·摩根斯恩在《纽约客》中所讲述的那样，
the college student, the young hero of our our story was lost to history. Okay, wait for it. Wait for this moment. It's a good one. Here it comes. It would have been some time in the early 90s. I remember being upstairs in my bedroom and had one of my sons. He was sort of hanging off me as I was trying to put him down to go to bed. And suddenly my husband who had been downstairs started yelling a little bit and saying, Diane, Diane, quick, quick turn on the TV. Your thesis building is on TV. This is Diane Hottley. As far as we can tell, she was the student in the measure story. And so I, you know, holding the baby with one arm, I fumbled for the remote and got to the channel
那个大学生，我们故事中的年轻英雄，在历史中被遗忘了。好吧，等一下。等待这一刻。这是一个好时刻。它来了。那应该是在90年代初期的某个时候。我记得我在楼上的卧室里，我的一个儿子正挂在我身上，当时我正试图把他放下睡觉。突然，一直在楼下的丈夫开始大声喊叫，说：“黛安，黛安，快，快打开电视。你的论文建筑正在电视上。”这是黛安·霍特利。据我们所知，她就是勒梅苏尔故事中的那个学生。所以，我一边用一只手臂抱着婴儿，一边摸索着遥控器，调到了那个频道，
just in time to hear... This building could have killed tens of thousands of people. The extraordinary chain of events began with a phone call out of the blutes from a student in New Jersey whose professor had told him to write a paper on the city called Tower. William Lamejert. And I explained to the student in the telephone call that he could tell his professor. I was a guest. I nearly dropped my baby. This was the first time Diane had ever heard of the emergency retrofits around the clock
正好赶上听到……这座建筑可能会杀死数万人。这起非同寻常的事件链始于一个来自新泽西的学生的突如其来的电话，他的教授曾告诉他写一篇关于花旗集团大楼的论文。威廉·勒梅苏尔。我在电话里向这位学生解释说，她可以告诉她的教授。我是一个客人。我差点把婴儿掉在地上。这是黛安第一次听说围绕着大楼展开的紧急加固、全天候气象监测、疏散计划以及一名学生的参与。
weather monitoring the evacuation plans in the involvement of a student. So, when she heard LaMesa reference a student, a male student, I, of course, assumed, you know, gosh, there was some guide studying the building as well. And wow, you know, how could I miss this? Wow. So, it was pretty remarkable, but I, of course, assumed at the time that there was another fellow who had been a better researcher than I had been. In fact, Diane never even considered that she might be the student in the story. That is, until she went to a Princeton event honoring her thesis advisor David Billington.
所以，当她听到勒梅苏尔提到一个学生，一个男学生时，我当然以为，天哪，肯定有某个男导游也在研究这座建筑。天哪，我怎么会错过这个？哇。所以，这相当了不起，但我当时当然认为还有另一个同行研究员比我做得更好。事实上，黛安甚至从未想过自己可能是故事中的那个学生。直到她去参加普林斯顿大学一场纪念她的论文导师大卫·比林顿的活动。
When I showed up at the event, David said, well, have you ever heard of the problems with the City Corp Center? And I said, yes, have you ever heard of the problems with the City Corp Center? And I said, yes, isn't that pretty remarkable? I wonder who it was that discovered this problem. And he said, you know, Diane, there are very few engineering schools in New Jersey. And quite frankly, I know all of them. And I know the heads of the programs of all of them and I've talked to all of them There was no other student from New Jersey that was studying the building except for you
当我出现在活动现场时，大卫说：“嗯，你听说过花旗集团中心的问题吗？”我说：“是的，你听说过花旗集团中心的问题吗？”我说：“是的，这不是很了不起吗？我不知道是谁发现了这个问题。”他说：“你知道，黛安，新泽西州很少有工程学院。坦白说，我都认识。我也认识其中所有项目的负责人，我都和他们谈过。没有其他来自新泽西的学生在研究这座建筑，除了你。”
So it must have been you. Yes, it's I don't know about any other student This is David Billington the thesis advisor. Yes, my name is David Billington That's correct and I'm an engineer thesis advisor. Yes, my name is David Billington, that's correct, and I'm an engineer, spent 53 years at Princeton as a faculty member. I was Diane Hartley's thesis advisor. She wrote the most outstanding thesis of anybody who was a very low of your seeing it. Two big volumes, yes, anyway.
所以那一定是你。是的，就是我，我不知道还有没有别的学生。这是论文导师大卫·比林顿。是的，我的名字是大卫·比林顿。没错，我是一名工程师。在普林斯顿担任教职53年。我是黛安·霍特利的论文导师。她写了所有人中最为出色的论文，你肯定看过。两本大厚册子，是的，不管怎样。
To hear Diane Hartley and David Billington tell the story, Diane wasn't some in your face nodal. Here's her version of the events. So I was 21 years old and I was a senior at Princeton University where I was studying architecture and urban planning. My thesis, I had selected the topic of the City Corp Center in New York, which had only recently been completed and occupied. She reached out to Lamejus firm to get the calculations that they had run, and then she tried
听黛安·霍特利和大卫·比林顿讲述这个故事，黛安并不是那种盛气凌人的书呆子。以下是她对事件的描述。所以当时我21岁，我是普林斯顿大学的大四学生，在那里我学习建筑和城市规划。我的毕业论文，我选择了纽约的花旗集团中心作为主题，该中心才刚刚完工并投入使用。她联系了勒梅苏尔的公司以获取他们运行的计算数据，然后她尝试
to replicate the math herself. To do the work again from the start and see if she got the same answers as Lamejus engineers. David Billington, her advisor, asked her to ask Lamejus firm about the quartering winds. The quartering wind, I thought that was a problem and that it should be looked at. So I obtained calculations from the design engineer from Lamejus office and I concluded the governing loading condition was the wind hitting the corner of the building. But the math just wasn't coming out right.
自己重新推演数学计算。从头开始重新做这项工作，看看她是否能得到与勒梅苏尔的工程师相同的答案。她的导师大卫·比林顿要求她向勒梅苏尔的公司询问关于斜向风的情况。斜向风，我认为这是一个问题，应该对其进行研究。所以我从勒梅苏尔办公室的设计工程师那里获得了计算结果，我得出的结论是，主导荷载条件是风撞击建筑物的角落。但数学计算结果总是不对劲。
I was struggling with the calculations. I assumed, of course, that the engineer had done the right thing and any inconsistency that I might find would be my error. The building was standing. After all, she was just a college senior and LaMessia and his people were established, internationally renowned, professional, structural engineers. Diane got back in touch with LaMessia's firm, although she never talked with LaMessia herself. I never called LaMessia, I never said these things that were documented in the various reports that had been published today.
我在计算中苦苦挣扎。当然，我假设工程师做了正确的事情，我可能发现的任何不一致之处都会是我自己的错误。毕竟建筑还立在那里。她只是一名大学大四学生，而勒梅苏尔和他的团队是老牌的、国际知名的专业结构工程师。黛安重新联系了勒梅苏尔的公司，尽管她从未与勒梅苏尔本人交谈过。我从未给勒梅苏尔打过电话，我从未说过那些今天已经发表的各种报告中记录的这些话。
Diane did talk to a junior engineer, LaMeshna's New York office, named Joel Weinstein. She showed him her calculations. But at the end of the day, no, I didn't feel that I had put my finger on a major problem. I assumed I was wrong and wasn't understanding things. Even David Bellinton, who had told Diane to look into the quartering winds in the first place, didn't think there was any imminent threat. I mean, I don't think either of us really were in a position to say at the time, you've got to do something Bill right away.
黛安确实与勒梅苏尔纽约办公室的一位初级工程师交谈过，他叫乔尔·温斯坦。她向他展示了她的计算结果。但归根结底，不，我不觉得我触及了一个重大问题。我以为我错了，没有理解事情。甚至连最初告诉黛安去调查斜向风的大卫·比林顿，也不认为有什么迫在眉睫的威胁。我的意思是，我不认为我们俩当时都处于能够说“比尔你必须马上做点什么”的立场。
We didn't have that feeling. I had the feeling that she should talk to the designers and find out whether this quartering wind had been considered and if so what was the outcome. But somehow Diane's discovery got silently passed up the totem bowl within LeMessage's firm. We asked Joel Weinstein the engineer about meeting check with Bill. I would have been the logical thing to do and he probably did that. I never heard that. You never heard it, I guess. We asked Joel Weinstein the engineer about meeting Diane and what happened afterwards, but he says he has no memory of this either way. Though he does acknowledge that if Diane
我们没有那种感觉。我觉得她应该和设计人员谈谈，弄清楚是否考虑过这种斜向风，如果是的话结果是什么。但不知何故，黛安的发现悄无声息地传到了勒梅苏尔公司内部权力结构的顶端。我们问工程师乔尔·温斯坦关于和比尔核对的情况。这本该是顺理成章的事，他可能也那样做了。我从没听说过。你没听说过，我猜。我们问工程师乔尔·温斯坦关于见到黛安以及之后发生的事情，但他说他对此没有任何记忆。尽管他承认如果黛安
remembered speaking to him, then it probably happened. And that in such a circumstance, he would have passed her message on to LeMeshah. So it could be that's why LeMameja remembers speaking to a male student. He was conflating Diane Hartley, the student with Joel Weinstein, his own staffer. Now, of course, it is possible that there was a male student. A third man. Who somehow had the same data as Diane and actually did talk to Lameja on the phone. But I find it really hard to believe that such a person didn't come forward and claim
记得和他说过话，那么这可能确实发生了。并且在这种情况下，他会把她的消息传给勒梅苏尔。所以这可能就是为什么勒梅苏尔记得和一个男学生谈过话。他把学生黛安·霍特利和他的员工乔尔·温斯坦搞混了。现在，当然，确实有可能存在一个男学生。第三个人。不知何故，他拥有和黛安相同的数据，并且确实在电话里和勒梅苏尔谈过。但我真的很难相信这样一个人在故事曝光后没有站出来抢占聚光灯。
the spotlight after the story broke. Gender aside, Diane definitely doesn't fit the image of the precocious student. She identified a problem without even recognizing the significance of what she had done for decades. It's not that I did something. It's that perhaps my questions helped someone figure something out. Perhaps my questions were meant to be. I think if I had really realized that there was a problem and put my finger on it and raised it up the flagpole, I could pat myself on the back for having done something that was pretty remarkable. But at the end of the day, I feel like I was a bit player in a play
抛开性别不谈，黛安绝对不符合那个早熟学生的形象。她发现了一个问题，甚至几十年来都没有意识到自己所做的事情有多么重大。不是我做了什么。也许是我的问题帮助某人弄明白了什么。也许我的问题是命中注定的。我想如果我真的意识到有问题并指出来并把它向上汇报，我可以为自己做了一件相当了不起的事情而自我感觉良好。但归根结底，我觉得自己是一部大团圆结局戏剧中的一个微不足道的小演员。
that had a happy ending. So yes, she deserves more credit than she's gotten. You can tell her that. I think that's right. That's the, I think, the code for this. 99% Invisible was produced this week by Joel Werner and Sam Greenspan, with Katie Mingle Avery Troubleman and me Roman Mars. Special thanks to Michael Verdaro, who wrote the AI-A Trust White Paper about City Corp Center, Samille Raghavan at the National Academy of Engineering for help and has tracked down archival audio of William LaMesa and Alan Bello's of the website, Damn Interesting for talking to me about this about two years ago at this point.
所以是的，她应得的赞誉比她实际得到的要多。你可以告诉她。我认为这很对。我想，这就是对此的共识。本周的“99%隐形”由乔尔·维纳和萨姆·格林斯潘制作，凯蒂·明格、艾弗里·特拉布曼以及我罗曼·马尔斯协助制作。特别感谢迈克尔·韦达罗，他撰写了关于花旗集团中心的 AIA 信任白皮书；感谢国家工程院的萨米尔·拉加万提供的帮助，他帮我追踪了威廉·勒梅苏尔的档案音频；还要感谢网站“Damn Interesting”的阿兰·贝洛斯，大约两年前就这件事和我进行了交谈。
We are a Project 91.7 Local Public Radio KALW in San Francisco and produced out of the offices of ArcSign, beautiful architecture firm and beautiful downtown Oakland, California. You can keep up with this show and all the people who make this show on Facebook, Twitter, and Tumblr. If you want to see some pictures of CityCorp Center, go to 99pi.org. All right, I make sure you say that. Wait, sorry, I said something. I say this is not architecture we're talking about.
我们是旧金山 91.7 频道本地公共广播 KALW 的一个项目，在奥克兰市中心美丽的建筑事务所 ArcSign 的办公室制作。你可以在 Facebook、Twitter 和 Tumblr 上关注这个节目以及所有制作这个节目的人。如果你想看一些花旗集团中心的照片，请访问 99pi.org。好的，我确保你这么说。等等，抱歉，我刚才说错了。我说这不是我们谈论的建筑。
This is structure, engineering structure. I'm very sensitive about that. I don't want to mix up these things. I think that in this case, the measures design was a brilliant structural design but it was all covered over typical of architects to cover it over so you could never see it. Most people make that decision about tall buildings that they wanted to be architecture and that's why most of them are so
这是结构，工程结构。我对这一点非常敏感。我不想把这些东西混为一谈。我认为在这个案例中，勒梅苏尔的设计是一个绝妙的结构设计，但它全被遮盖起来了，这是建筑师的典型做法，把它遮盖起来让你永远看不见。大多数人对高层建筑做出那样的决定，是因为他们希望它是建筑艺术，这就是为什么其中大多数都那么
bad. But anyway that's a prejudice. So it will be clear this is structure not architecture. But what we're talking clear this is structured not architecture. But what we're talking about is structure, not architecture. Radio to be. From PRX. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
糟糕。但无论如何，那是一种偏见。所以我们要明确，这是结构，不是建筑。但我们要明确，这是结构，不是建筑。但我们讨论的是结构，而不是建筑。电台即将播出。来自 PRX。本集尚无评论。点击转录文本中的任何句子即可发表评论。